hello everyone and welcome back to the
Women's World Chess Championship it's
Alexander Goryeo China with the white
pieces against jewel when June and it's
game 5 if you've been following the
coverage so far
and by coverage I mean the one game
we've covered the first three games
ended in a draw then Joanne joong-won
won her first game and now it's well
good actually now really needs to bounce
back if she wants to get back into the
fight for the title so like I said the
first six games will be played in
Shanghai China and then the other six in
Wadi Bostock Russia so this is still
being played in China without further
ado let's check it out it is a very nice
game so we're just gonna with the white
pieces opens with C for the English
opening now we have Knight to f6 Knight
to c3 with East six and E for the
McKenna's variation of the English and
d5 striking in the center we have C
captures it captures in the now II five
attacking the knight on f6 and now
Knight to e4 d 4 is also playable here
and statistically even black has a
better results with with this move
however it's you know a personal
preference I guess would you prefer so
nice to e4 and nice to f3 continuing
development with Bishop to f5 black does
the same end now d3 kicking away the
night and the night will now capture and
improve White's central pawn structure
so d4 is coming and white will have a
very nice Center c5 continuing the fight
for the central squares we have d4 and
Queen to a5 now pinning the siege report
but also just threatening threatening to
capture it with Bishop to b2 blocking
and Knight to c6
Julian continues developing pieces and
fighting for the center and here this
allows white this breakthrough in the
center c4 which comes with an attack on
the Queen and this is still all
considered theory Queen back to the 8th
and now there is only one good move here
for white that well theory agrees that
gives a white the advantage its Queen to
b3 and it's a very it's a known position
for example it was reached in the in
Batumi in Georgia in the 2018
olympiad between an apology and
Vishwanathan Anand where bishop the east
sex was played that game ended in a draw
but here a Jew engine decides for Bishop
to c4 to keep to keep the point one
defender with the bishop from efore and
also it puts pressure on the knight on
f3 it's not a new move it has been
played before and we have Queen captures
on b7 now grabbing a pawn threatening to
capture the night rook the c8 defending
and now there is one game in the
database where Knights the g5 was played
and it's very interesting Knight to g5
is the engines top recommendation
whereas garage gonna play Bishop to g5
and this is a move not even considered
by the engine you know okay if you
consider maybe the engine's top top five
or maybe top ten recommendations I'm
sure Bishop to g5 will be there but it's
not amongst the top three so it's very
interesting it's definitely home-brewed
poisonous preparation and it will be
very interesting to see how how do
engine will deal with this Bishop to g5
move as it's it's I I would say it's
impossible to imagine that she she
prepared for this move and of course it
is a new move in the position so it is
as a move 14 that we have a completely
new game so basically you're deciding
between Queen b7 Queen c7 and Bishop to
e7 blocking the bishops attack towards
the Queen Queen d7 you kinda don't want
to play as captures captures your King
loses castling castling rights which
maybe isn't such a bad thing since you
kind of do want to keep your King here
in the middle of the board when the
Queen's are off the board but there are
still a lot of pieces here so maybe
maybe not that so if Queen to c7 then
white can just trade captures captures
captures here Bishop recaptures and
Bishop to b5 the route is coming to c1
is gonna put a lot of pressure here so
it's hard to say what what you would do
here but it's it perhaps is playable but
not very enjoyable and especially if you
go for characters captors and captures
which wins wins upon but then rook the
c1 will be will be terrible for black
you have to defend King here the knight
is under attack twice also it's been
just Bishop f4 e 6 is coming
and definitely something we're actually
not prepared if if black decides for
this defense so instead after Bishop to
g5 we have Bishop to e7 and now Bishop
captures on e7 with Knight captures on
e7 and now Quinta b5 with check asking
are you ready to move the King at which
point maybe I can capture and then
capture on c5 create a path C pawn of
course now Julian is not interested
Queen to d7 is played we have C captures
on d5 Bishop captures and now Queen
captures on d7 King captures on d7 and
here comes that Bishop to b5 check so
what do you play here well it's not it's
not all that Pleasant for the black King
for example you you do not want to block
with the bishop if Bishop here just a
four and it's it's a perfectly well not
not not fine but it's a great position
for white for example you you you cannot
capture if you capture than just Knight
captures it's it's it's a really active
position for white bishop characters
you're gonna go a captures the a7 point
is now weak you don't have time to bring
the rook into the game and it's well
it's very enjoyable for white so instead
after this Bishop to b5 check move with
King to e6 it's a bold move since it's
inviting the Knights to g5 to take the
King further for the walk if you imagine
for example if if the black king did not
have access to the f5 square Knight to
g5 would be made fortunately for black
you do not have access to something like
g4 since the knight is hanging it's ok
Knights the g5 with check King to f5 and
now h4 there are cementing that night
and on g5 maybe not cementing you can
always kick it away but defending it and
preparing Bishop to d7 check so here
black has to make a choice of whether
it's moving the King not allowing this
check but then you allow Bishop d3 check
and King to h6 and that's just a just a
terrible position for the King and even
if it might be playable with the engine
moves it's for a human you do not want
to put your King in such a position you
can go rogue g1 g4 and it's gonna be
well not a lot of breathing room for
that the black King there so instead
besides for the active defense she
decides to pick up the two central pawns
and give up the exchange she plays seek
actress on d4 Bishop to d7 with Trek and
now King captures on e5
we have Bishop captures on c8 and now
rook captures on CA so here Joe engine
is up upon down the exchange but she
does have the very strong past deep on
so let's see how this unwinds with
castles now the rook is ready to enter
the game King back to d6 now we have
rook F e1 putting in the work to to an
open e file and now rook the c2 grabbing
more space with the rook it's a very
active square for the rook has a lot of
control over the second rank and now a
3d a coupon is no longer a target so now
you can move your look with h6 pushing
the knight back Knight to e4 check and
now Bishop captures on e4 this is a very
interesting decision since the bishop is
a useful piece here attacking the King
side for example you cannot put the F
pawn because there are a lot of threats
towards the g2 pawn but the knight is
also a very strong piece in the center
of the board so Jew decides to get rid
of it Bishop captures rook captures and
Knight to c6 just defending the pass
pawn and now we have h5 stopping further
expansion by black on the Kings side and
here King to d5 seems to be the
reasonable choice can be 5 you push away
the rook you put d3 d2 but black first
decided to play g6 it's hard to imagine
why since it's never in your best
interest to capture here to ruin your
your pawn structure and this gives a
white contra attacking chances with rook
to f4 now you can no longer push f5
because well if f5 just captures here
and now White has a very strong passport
so here black is forced to capture on h5
wheel G captures an h5 rook captures on
f7 and only now does she push d3 and
okay rook d1
stopping the pawn and now d2 and now
it's already there's the threat of rook
to C 1 which would just win the game so
how do you defend this with white feel
free to pause the video and try to find
what you would
play here with the white pieces while I
give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on finding one of the
one of the two good defensive ideas a
one is working H - it just doesn't allow
rook to c1 to come with a pin but there
is an even better active move which you
played sorry which we're actually in a
plate which is rook to f3 which is quite
simple now rook to c1 will be met with
rook to d3 check King moves you pick up
the pawn and black has no more counter
play it's three pounds each but white is
up the exchange so instead after this
rook to f3
of course Knight to e5 was played
kicking away the rook also not allowing
rook the d3 check we have looked the f4
now again with the idea of checking and
picking up the pawn but now again feel
free to pause the video and try to find
the best move for black while I give you
a couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it congratulations
and being a spectacular end game player
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it's nice to see for this
is the correct the correct move however
black played Knight to c6 the difference
is with night the C 60s you do have
control over the d4 square so the check
is not possible but Knight to c4 is an
attacking move and it prepares the
knight the b2 which will get rid of the
rook on d1 so for example if King f1 and
also this does nothing this check does
nothing the King will just attack the
rook and the knight and rook already
protect the d2 pawn so here King f1 King
e5 you push away the rook rook h4 Knight
B 2 wins back the exchange it doesn't
matter you will lose this with checking
before King e2 now you grab it captures
captures and well just rotate to and
it's a it's a Ronin game so nice to see
4 would have been excellent here however
Knights the c6 was played and now again
pause the video and try to find the only
winning move for white while I give you
a couple of seconds so for those of you
who were able to do it along with the
two previous ones congratulations you
are you were basically playing a World
Championship game and for those who just
want to enjoy
so it's kinked f1 and now that the king
is an f1 having access to the e2 square
black no longer has any threats rook to
c1 is no longer a threat just kingi -
it's pointless you don't want to trade
next move white will win win the past
pawn so everything is working out for
white nicely so King to f1 of course was
played by Goryeo China we have king that
he five and now rogue back to f3 now
Knight to a5 hoping hoping to reach that
c4 and this to kick away the rook but
it's too late for such things just King
e2 we have nice the c-4 attacking the a3
pawn but now rook the h3 preparing to
pick up these these pawns with check we
have looked to a two now again attacking
the a3 pawn but just rook h5 check King
to d4 and now rook h4 check came back to
c5 and now look back to h3 again the
problem being you don't know you do not
have Knight captures here because of
route capture Sundy to
captures captures and well it's just two
points each where black is down the
exchange so of course completely winning
for white so we have a five instead but
now f4 Nagaraj Cana is ready to push her
point with King d5 now rook the f3 of
course putting the rug behind the passed
pawn king g6 and now g4 we have a four
by do engine and now rook the h3
preparing to get rid of this point as
well so King bee 5 not allowing this to
come with check but now of course just
f5 continuing to push the passport and
this there's no there's no hurry to pick
up the h6 pawn so we have King back to
e5 but now rook the c3 attacking the
knight and here black just had to play
something she played Knight captures on
a3 with the idea that it's it's a little
trick now if you go for route capture
Sundy - you just get rook captures
captures and nice to be one check which
would wear well white would blunder the
game in a sense that white will not win
this game any longer for example king c2
captures captures and h5 and it's a draw
there's there's nothing to do if you
push just captures and if you capture
just captures and the King will pick up
this point this King will pick up this
phone and it
draw by insufficient material so after
night captures on a three of course
garage can a plate look the c-5 check
instead we have kink the b6 and now the
beautiful f6 saying okay if you capture
my rope I'm just gonna play f7 and there
is nothing you can do to stop my past F
pawn so a good Jew play tonight the c2
instead now trying to meet f7 good night
study for check King moves and the night
the e6 for the night will be defending
the queening square still winning for
white but you don't want to give give
black any any chances unnecessary
chances so after nights the c2 just rook
C for taking away the d4 square from the
night we have night back the a3 and now
rook the F for putting the rook in front
behind the past pawn and here I don't
know if King DIF I was played or or
maybe the the electronic board just
picked up the the King move but it was
in this position that did you when you
and resigned the game and the first win
in this match for Alexander Korea China
who equalizes and bounces back and now
there is one more game to be played in
Shanghai today so we'll see how that
goes but yeah now it's pointless because
after the King moves just f7 f8 Queen
it's unstoppable the rook cannot cannot
join in the action the knight has no
waste of even approaching the pawn the
rook nicely controls the the
fourth-ranked and it's just it's just
over so that was the moment in the game
when that decision to play with the
night after this rook to f4 move whether
to go knight c6 to guard the d4 square
or to go Knight to c4 which allows rook
d4 check but rugby for check is
pointless here because the d2 point is
defended you're just gonna go closer
with the king kick away the rook and
then force force
well white weight to lose the exchange
this was the way to go but it's yeah
this is this is the difference between
drawing a world championship game and
losing vulture championship game so we
might we might even use this no no we
will not use this as a thumbnail sense
it will you know they'll tell you where
to go but yeah that's the game I do hope
you enjoyed it Game five of the
Women's World Chess Championship match
twenty20 between Alexandra Gauri Akina
and you in June I do hope you enjoy that
I would like to thank George Taylor
Jacko be a Twin Falls company Gustavo
kanya in Carl's Montero for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - in my previous video ciarán
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Women's World Chess Championship the
Tata Steel and yes still preparing the
Paul Morphy saga along with checking up
on your wonderful suggestions so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day